qué tal Raúl muy buenos días Pues
expectativa como usted lo dice entre los
más de 30 mil personas que diariamente
cruzan este puente internacional Simón
Bolívar que conecta a el departamento de
norte de Santander del lado colombiano y
el estado de táchira del lado venezolano
serán más de 300 periodistas Entonces
los que cubran este evento entre
periodistas y camarógrafos acreditados
hacia las nueve de la mañana hora
colombiana 10 de la mañana hora
venezolana estarán aquí las delegaciones
de ambos países encabezadas del lado
colombiano por el presidente Gustavo
Petro que confirmó su llegada acá con
los ministros de
comercio exterior también el ministro de
transporte y su
canciller Álvaro Leyva entre otras
autoridades locales sin embargo hay que
ser precisos en algo Y es que esta
apertura es solamente para el transporte
de carga por ahora y la frontera aérea
Pero hay escepticismo también entre las
personas que están esperando una fecha
exacta Cuándo va a ser la reapertura del
paso de vehículos particulares y también
de transporte municipal hablamos con
algunos de ellos y eso fue lo que nos
dijeron No yo pienso no vienen positivo
Yo pienso que las actividades económicas
entre los países son necesarias
inclusive el caso de la salud para
nosotros en este momento pues es
bastante crítico en Venezuela por ahora
Pues las personas que transitamos a pie
seguimos con las mismas estos dudas por
cuanto Esperamos que se reaperturaron
nuevamente el transporte vehicular pero
vemos Que no que solamente por ahora
está informado para el transporte de
carga Entonces desde el punto de vista
social las personas que transitamos a
pie no es una gran mejora sino todavía
no veo cuál es la ventaja para nosotros
bueno Dani por supuesto muy pendientes
no a lo que va a hacer es este acto Y
también si va a ir entonces el
presidente venezolano Nicolás Maduro que
precisamente se lo vamos a preguntar en
este momento a nuestra auto en viaje
especial del lado venezolano en el
estado táchira herminia Fernández
herminia La saludo nuevamente muy buen
Cuál es el ambiente que se vio en este
momento y que se espera en esta
reapertura digamos ya se sabe si el
presidente venezolano Nicolás Maduro irá
a este acto
hola hola
sí Raúl la información de este lado del
del país digamos de Venezuela ha sido
muy poca acerca de la presencia de las
autoridades venezolanas si está
confirmado Confirmamos en France 24 a
través de fuentes que viene el ministro
de transporte
Hipólito Abreu que viene el gobernador
del estado táchira Freddy Bernal pero no
se sabe nada Hay que viene también el
embajador de Colombia y Venezuela en
Colombia Félix Placencia pero no se ha
confirmado la presencia del presidente
Nicolás maduro y normalmente a estas
alturas debería estar casa militar que
sería como la señal de que sí va a estar
el primer mandatario venezolano sin
embargo solo hay seguridad de ejército
de guardia nacional y de militares de
inteligencia como el sebismo acá sigue
la gente esperando no de mucha
expectativa económica como dije hace
unos momentos todos interesados en que
mejore la situación económica para los
venezolanos
están en la frontera porque ha estado
muy deprimido últimamente pero también
hay otro tema muy importante que quieren
que mejore que es el tema de la
seguridad acá en la frontera se habla de
que hay unas 15 agrupaciones delictivas
entre guerrilla disidencia eh También
bandas delincuenciales venezolanas el
gobernador del estado táchira Freddy
Bernal decía hace un par de días que van
a empezar a atacar a estas bandas que
funcionan en los caminos verdes o los
llamados trochas porque una vez que se
abra el paso seguramente van a ir a
extorsionar a los comerciantes Entonces
el gobernador Bernal decía que se va a
abrir un camino de comunicación directo
con los comerciantes para que ellos
informen cuando esto vaya a suceder